[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport le
magazine est consacrée comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département c'est parti à pour le
sommaire volley ball l'équipe masculine
de vélizy l'a emporté ce week-end contre
saint-avertin domicile le score 3 sets à
le résumé du match dans ce magazine
cyclisme sur piste quentin lafargue a
été élu sportif yvelinois de l'année par
notre rédaction la tête a notamment
remporté une médaille d'or aux
championnats du monde son portrait dans
ce magazine sport de combat un stage de
coup de pouce sera donné à villepreux ce
dimanche 15 décembre au profit des
réfugiés tibétains arrivé la semaine
dernière dans la ville nous recevrons
les organisateurs enfin à des missions
l'actualité sportive de la semaine c'est
maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
on commence tout de suite par un
résultat de coupe de france de football
ont joué ce week-end le 8e tour de la
compétition
versailles dernier représentant évinois
encore en course va continuer l aventure
de versailles ont réussi à s'imposer 3
buts à 0 sur le terrain de vire une
équipe qui évolue également en nationale
3 les trois buts ont été inscrits par
l'attaquant yoan akassou on écoute
l'entraîneur de versailles youssef
chebbi qui retient avant tout à l'état
d'esprit c'est une compétition
particulière ou appui en avant mains
plus ça devient difficile et plus on a
besoin de deux de valeur comme comme le
courage l'abnégation la solidarité pour
pouvoir franchir les paliers et
aujourd'hui en termes de cohésion et
solidarité à mon équipe a franchi un pas
et aujourd'hui voilà le résultat de ce
travail de ce parcours puisque on a six
matchs cette saison de coupe de france
et si qualification consécutive cette
qualification est une première en dix
ans pour les versailles et au prochain
tour versailles pourrait affronter un
club de ligue 1 au mois de janvier
le tirage au sort aura lieu ce soir on
continue par du football et le
championnat de première division de
district ont joué ce week-end deux
matches en retard voisins le bretonneux
maurepas se sont neutralisés 1 but
partout
de son côté à le chine et s'est incliné
contre hardricourt sur le score de 2
buts à 1 au classement voisins se
retrouvent cinquièmes le chesnais 10e au
repas est co-leader à gargenville les
deux équipes comptent sept victoires
depuis le début de la saison la dixième
journée est programmée à ce week end il
y avait également du rugby ce week-end
en championnat de fédérale 2 plaisir se
reprend sur le terrain d'orléans les
pays roi se sont imposés 20 à 18 après
trois défaites consécutives au
classement les événements restent à la
10e place avec trois victoires au
compteur depuis le début de la saison
plaisir à six points d'avancé sur le
premier relégable lors furent en
fédérale 3 de rugby versailles n'a pas
réussi à s'imposer sur le terrain de
pithiviers retiennent ce week-end score
final 14 à 10 les versaillais prennent
tout de même le point de bonus défensif
au classement cette deuxième défaite
consécutive et un coup d'arrêt
versailles se retrouve 4e à égalité avec
bobigny et voit surtout les autres
équipes revenir prochain match dimanche
prochain à 15 heures à domicile contre
boulogne billancourt dans le championnat
honneur de rugby d'union rugby 178 s'est
incliné ce dimanche contre lasnier rugby
à l'extérieur sur le score de 24 à 18
le rc 78 se retrouvent quatrièmes
ex-aequo au classement avec paris après
un excellent début de saison les saint
quentinois ce déplacement dimanche
prochain sur la pelouse du red star à
l'occasion de la 10e journée fia on va
maintenant parler à de volley ball
vélizy et recevez saint-avertin ce
week-end dans la salle et dans leur
salle et les illilois l'ont emporté
assez facilement 3 sets à 0
le résumé du match avantage de eyes est
déjà un match pour rester dans la course
à la montée vélizy rosso et
saint-avertin les derniers du classement
pour le compte de la 7ème journée de
nationale 3 car en place tactiquement
les béliziens remporte les deux premiers
sets sur les scores de 25 22 et 25 21
premier set c'était un petit peu
compliqué au début quand même il n'y en
a pas tués à prendre le dessus sur le
rapport service recep la fin on a fait
le petit décalage deuxième on a bien
déroulé dans le troisième set les
joueurs de florian guillou sous son plus
en difficulté il arrive finalement
l'emporter 29 à 27 après avoir failli
concéder le set
bilan de cette rencontre trois sets à
zéro sur le troisième set il ya eu un
réveil de l'équipe adverse nous a pas
facilité la tâche qui a bien servi nous
on a fait des petites des petites
erreurs un peu bêtes des ballons qui
tombe sans personnes se jettent dessus
et c'était compliqué on a su la fin
resserrer les vis cette victoire permet
à l'équipe d'occuper la troisième place
du classement avec un bilan de cinq
victoires en sept journées disputées
des résultats qui permettent au club de
regarder vers le haut du classement
l'objectif primordial fait le maintien
déjà la dre qui peut le moins peut le
plus en vrai dire donc si on peut aller
chercher quelque chose de
montée en fin de saison où une place sur
le podium
on s'en privera pas pour rêver toujours
plus grands les waeslandiens se
déplaceront le 12 janvier sur le teint
de cercle jules-ferry les premiers du
classement en attendant le club passera
de belles fêtes de fin d'année l'équipe
féminine de vélizy joue est également ce
week-end dans le championnat de
nationale 3 et les bélizienne se sont
inclinés à 3 sets à 0 avec un 14 à 25
dans le deuxième set
un match qui reflète le début de saison
compliqué de l'équipe les filles pointe
à la 9e place sur 11 équipes engagées
avec seulement une victoire on écoute
les différentes réactions micro de tv 78
[Musique]
on perd tous les suivants donc très
compliqué après il ya une grosse remise
en question de toute l'équipe on a
beaucoup discuté
ça fait deux semaines que nous
entraînements sont de meilleure qualité
on attend que ça se voit sur sur les
machines les faits me sens un peu plus
en difficulté c'est une équipe qui est
pas mal renouvelée par rapport à la
saison dernière sont perdus leur
passeuse titulaires elles ont perdu la
point de vue
donc ya pas mal de pas mal de renouveau
une dernière information volley-ball
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines serait en
négociations avancées pour organiser une
rencontre de première division ligue à
le match se déroulerait courant mars
avril dans la structure le dossier sur
est en phase de finalisation et pourrait
concerner deux équipes de haut de
tableau on parle de tours et de paris
l'officialisation devrait intervenir
courant janvier
il y avait du basket également ce
week-end dans le championnat de
nationale 3 à 10e journée trappe s'est
imposée 64 à 59 sur le terrain de
montville son côté le chesnay versailles
a perdu pour la deuxième fois de la
saison à l'extérieur face à bihorel 79 à
66 au classement le fcv 78 se retrouve à
la troisième place trappe pointe à la
cinquième place du championnat à trois
points de saint thomas en ballon jouer
en nationale 3 parmi les principaux
résultats ce samedi plaisir s'est imposé
29 à 27 à domicile face à saint mandé
une victoire synonyme de bouffée
d'oxygène pour le club les plaisirs oies
se retrouve à la 9e place du championnat
et prennent trois points d'avancé sur le
premier relégable
prochain match samedi prochain sur le
terrain de saint michel on va maintenant
ouvrir une page handisport direction
montigny le bretonneux ils sont avec
nous sur ce plateau le club de handball
de la commune propose du handball en
fauteuil le club recrute pour nous
parler de cette section nous recevons
sur ce plateau stéphane de viser joueurs
handisport dans la structure ainsi
qu'olivier duval joueurs valides et
thierry bollègue entraîneur joueur dans
l'équipe
bonsoir messieurs bonsoir pouvez vous
nous présenter cette discipline alors
cette discipline les assez proche du de
l'état d'esprit en termes de handball en
fait on est juste en fauteuil
les règles sont identiques ou en 2
classique en termes d'impact en terme de
dribbles en termes de marché en termes
de zone
il faut savoir qu effectivement tous les
joueurs qu'ils soient donc valide ou
bandits sont en fauteuil
y compris les gardiens de but donc en
fauteuil vous par exemple vous êtes en
fauteuil actuellement en faute et de
compétition si je comprends bien
certains portails de compet il sert
aussi pour eux les actes quotidiens de
la vie et comment il est ce fauteuil
justement il est sur mesure au début
c'est un fauteuil de basket et après ben
je l'adapté pour les différents sports
que je fais comme le tennis et le mans
deux fauteuils olivier vous êtes un
joueur valide
qu'est ce que vous avez déjà joué world
handball avant oui et qu'est ce que ça
change comme comme beaucoup rigolé
qu'est ce que ça change par rapport au
handball handisport l'état d'esprit
comme des et tire exactement le même
donc ça ne change pas grand chose si ce
n'est qu'il faut réussir à appréhender
le fameux sièges pour les valides
sorti de là ya pas de y'a pas d'autres
différences par une balle au niveau
technique est ce qu'il ya des vraies
différences
est-ce qu'il faut être peut-être plus
précis peut-être dans la passe
absolument là vous avez raison c'est il
faut être plus précis parce que quand
vous êtes sur vos jambes
si la balle est un petit peu trop en
avant un petit peu trop en arrière il
est beaucoup plus facile de faire une
marche arrière quand on est sur ses deux
jambes quand on est sur un fauteuil
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué donc
effectivement il faut être beaucoup plus
précis dans tout ce qui est passe de
manière à ne pas mettre en difficulté en
fait le joueur à qui est destiné le
ballon voilà ça c'est effectivement une
des caractéristiques du hand fauteuil
par rapport aux en bas le classique ou
confirmé stéphane non je pense que c'est
totalement faux
une connaissance réelle du vent de
fauteuils en fait étant concernée en
tant que seul handicap et du club je le
précise parce que il faut qu'on bouche
les trous avec des yeux le père lui
comme ça mais sinon tu disais quoi parce
qu'il faut être plus précis oui mais
vous pouvez être plus précis parce que
bon il faut s'adapter à eux
et puis c'est pas souvent simples c'est
pas souvent simples moi même je aller
j'ai un handicap au niveau des mains
donc les passe en général je les réussis
pas tout le temps mais bon en général
ils arrivent à les rattraper cce les
champions en fait justement pourquoi
avoir voulu créé cette section à la fois
valides et handisports c'est pour
l'argent je crois un véritable besoin
d'argent et ont fait c'est pour sa joie
mais en fait ce qu'on a voulu faire
c'est justement abordé le pour nous les
valides le monde handicap mais non pas à
les regarder dans une sur un terrain
mais c'est effectivement jouer avec eux
donc c'est un échange entre ce genre de
denner humaine et nous donc nous on a
appris beaucoup sur le handicap
on a réussi à faire un gros et
finalement on a un jeu qui est collectif
avec bon c'est voila voila un petit peu
voilà un petit peu l'idée est ce que je
voulais moi aussi faire passer comme
message c'est qu'avant de parler de
joueurs andy j'aurais vraiment je
souhaite que l'on parle de joueurs parce
qu'en fait ils s'entraînent très très
dur 1 malgré l'étonnante facilité de
certains mais il s'entraîne très très
durs comme n'importe quel sportif et
l'idée c'est plutôt de voir en eux des
sportifs d'avoir une équipe de sport
leur en fauteuil c'est une équipe de
sport avec aussi quelques on dit voilà
olivier est ce que vous sentez plus
proche maintenant des sportifs
handisport en ayant pratiqué cette
discipline
ah oui avant c'était totalement inconnu
jusqu'à ce que thierry morin dans cette
aventure et puissamment ballet depuis
deux ans maintenant je pratique ce sport
qu'est le handball
parce que c'est un sport avant tout ça
fait quand même temps on vous en fait ça
fait deux ans deux ans j'ai toujours pas
progressé
malgré les 9 et 10 précieuse de ses fans
voilà tout à fait heureusement qu'il est
est ce que participer quand même des
compétitions
oui mais récemment on a gagné le tournoi
de montigné qu'on n'avait pas gagné
depuis je pars pas mal de temps déjà
et oui il ya du niveau et il faut
l'avouer c'est non il ya quelque chose
d'un mec est valide c'est facile pas
remporté une compétition je dois
répondre sincèrement parce qu'il ya
quand même l'entraîneur qui l'a donc oui
c'est génial joue avec eux c'est
toujours un grand plaisir
et puis voilà en fait s'il vous plaît
sur tes mots de la devise est justement
en préambule
vous recrutez également oui tout à fait
en fait l'idée pour nous valide ou
handisport valides ou
10 l'idée c'est effectivement de faire
connaître la discipline d'amener
d'autres personnes comme nous à côtoyer
des on dit bon alors évidemment on n'a
pas heureusement nous n'avons pas que
des phénomènes comme stéphane sinon ce
serait effectivement difficile à gérer
mais bon on y voit là il en fait partie
hélas hélas donc effectivement c'est un
pur des on dit aussi qu'ils pourraient
se dire ben je j'ai un handicap je sais
pas trop quoi faire
en fait il faut venir essayer il ya
possibilité effectivement de faire du
sport
sa vie de la tête de tous ces soucis
comme andy ou valide
on vient là au sport comme n'importe
quel sportif
et puis on revient chez soi on est quand
même en bien meilleure condition d'un la
question très rapidement comment on fait
pour vous rejoindre
alors pour nous rejoindre vous verrez la
police vous pouvez vous pouvez aller
liam et coordonnées sur le site donc de
montigny handball 78 ou sinon vous
pouvez venir le mardi soir le jeudi soir
pardon c'était l'année dernière le jeudi
soir au stade pierre de coubertin de 20h
à 22h15 vous pouvez venir essayer la
discipline que vous soyez en 10 ou
valide
merci à tous et roanne est passé sur ce
plateau avec votre bonne humeur merci
beaucoup on espère que ce passage vous
permettra de recruter des joueurs
handisport ou des joueurs valides on l'a
compris direction à présent à lille doit
zir de saint quentin en yvelines le
championnat régional de cyclo cross
était organisée ce dimanche sur le site
plusieurs centaines de participants dû
dompter à le parcours qui était à la
limite du praticable avec de la boue un
montage de à eghezée b du 500 m pour
tout donner ces jeunes cyclistes étaient
surmotivés ce dimanche humide et sombre
à l'occasion du championnat régional de
cyclo cross
le rendez vous organisé sur l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines a
réuni des catégories de sportifs de 6
ans jusqu'aux professionnels nous ont
beau avoir 10 ans 12 ans qui sont à bloc
ils n'ont qu'une envie c'est peut-être
un jour rejoindre le niveau
professionnel
aujourd'hui les conditions de course ne
sont pas idéales le thermomètre affiche
-2 8 degrés il appuie ses charges et de
pimenter encore un peu plus le parcours
c'est une véritable connexion
cyclo-cross la boule appuyé le vent bah
c'est ça le cyclo-cross les affaires du
soir à la sortie de la course première
réaction pour sept pilotes de l'extrême
c'est alors qu'il se dit fils d'abou des
sondés du vélo parfois mais je roulais
vite plutôt difficile à monter parce que
la première elle était plutôt facile je
les réussis mais la deuxième il y avait
tellement de gars doux que j'y arrivais
pas le rendez vous reviendra l'année
prochaine sur l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines les organisateurs
aimeraient également organiser une coupe
de france de la discipline dans quatre
ans nous avons profité de cet événement
pour rencontrer le cycliste de vie tels
concepts adrien garrel à tout juste 23
ans le cycliste originaire de
jouars-pontchartrain est l'un des
sportifs du département à suivre il
s'est prêté au jeu des trois questions
regardez la séquence
[Musique]
j'ai commencé le cyclisme pour ces
sports qui me plaisait jeter j'avais 6
ans je t'avais voir une course de vélo
en bretagne je me rappelle et ça m'a plu
j'ai dit à ma mère maman c'est ça que je
veux faire et après on n'a pas trouvé de
club à côté de la maison du coup j'ai
commencé par le vtt et après c'est qu'en
2010 que je suis allé au anciennement le
vcm eux qu'est devenu le vcs quand j'ai
commencé la compétition
[Musique]
j'irai montpetit de champion d'europe
accueille un bain à berlin au scratch
sur la piste en 2017
c'est juste mon premier gros résultat
international ça m'a permis de
m'affirmer justement à ce niveau là de
montrer que j'étais capable de faire de
belles choses et surtout c'est justement
parce h et professionnels donc ça va pas
me fier de prendre beaucoup confiance
l'avenir j'espère le plus longtemps
possible chez les professionnels là pour
l'instant avec vital concept bio tels
ans
on prépare la saison qu'on l'a on va
partir en stage
demain en espagne et puis enfin bon blog
de travail pour la meilleure saison
qu'il soit surtout pour les classiques
j'espère le tour des femmes on va faire
part aux baisses j'ai découvert mais bon
j'étais remplaçant du coup appelait des
rats minutes
j'aimerais vraiment gagner ma place
montré que je lai et du coup la préparer
à 200% et faire et accompagner le mieux
possible les leaders
coup de projecteur maintenant sur un
autre cycliste du vélo-club de l encours
saint-quentin-en-yvelines quentin
lafargue le sportif qui s'entraîne
quotidiennement vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines a remporté
trois titres majeurs à cette saison des
performances qui devrait l'emmener aux
jeux olympiques de tokyo l'année
prochaine en montage de xavier jeune
quentin lafargue c'est l'histoire d'une
mécanique bien rodée le pistard a
commencé le vélo à l'âge de 12 ans dans
une école de cyclisme en gironde
c'était en 2003 sur le vélodrome de
bordeaux
comme tous les jeunes j'ai vite quelques
résultats et
ça m'a surtout beaucoup plus toutes les
épreuves liées au sprint à la vitesse
j'avais un gabarit assez un corpulent
quand j'étais plus jeune et surtout plus
court plus corpulents que les autres et
du coup je prenais beaucoup de plaisir à
faire des disciplines de sprint
aujourd'hui quentin lafargue à 29 ans il
côtoie un autre vélodrome le national à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
c'est ici que le sportif décroche ses
premiers résultats sur la scène
internationale en 2016 l'athlète
remporté l'or sur le km lors des
championnats d'europe en 2015 première
médaille sur un championnat du monde
avec le bronze en vitesse individuelle
c'était vraiment le dernier sprint du
championnat après moi ans ils ont éteint
les lumières presque donc voilà c'est
une vraie
enfin une vraie belle image genre tiens
énormément d'émotion et voilà c'est 6000
personnes qui crient pour te faire
pédaler un tout petit peu plus vite ces
voix là je n'oublierai jamais ça 2015
une année particulière mais 2019 restera
une année unique pour quentin lafargue
le sportif a remporté cette année trois
titres trois médailles d'or sur le
kilomètre lors des mondiaux les
championnats d'europe et de france
une très belle saison 2010 n'est sur
laquelle physiquement j'ai montré que la
progression qu'on enfin suivait son
cours et est en tout cas qui donne
beaucoup de confiance pour la suite ça
faisait quelques années qui tournait
autour ont un peu autour du pot et je
dirais que cette année a été l'année de
la consécration de quentin mais ça fait
quand même quelques années qu'on consent
à volonté un peu faire des grands
résultats
des résultats qui permettent à son
équipe le vélo-club elancourt
saint-quentin-en-yvelines team vous sert
d'avoir un rayonnement international
quentin lafargue a rejoint cette
structure en novembre 2018
c'est une fierté c'est une fierté c'est
exceptionnel c'est quelqu'un de humble
humble et porté vers la jeunesse
un exemple quentin lafargue espère
maintenant décrocher son billet pour les
jeux olympiques de tokyo l'année
prochaine en espérant que 2020 soit une
aussi belle année que 2010 neuf hameaux
du téléthon l'événement caritatif sur
léa maladies génétiques neuromusculaires
et les maladies rares s'est déroulée le
week-end dernier plusieurs
manifestations sportives se sont
déroulées à travers les yvelines à
maurepas par exemple il y avait de la
gymnastique de la danse des arts
martiaux ou encore du handball fauteuil
plus insolite la miss mermaid france
2019 julie un peugeot à plonger en apnée
à la piscine du chéné rocancourt comme
on peut le voir sur ces photos on passe
maintenant notre page agenda
[Musique]
dans cet agenda nous allons parler d'une
belle initiative à villepreux un stage
au profit des réfugiés tibétains est
programmée ce dimanche 15 décembre à
l'espace michel petrucciani ça a fusé
sont arrivés la semaine dernière dans la
ville pour nous parler de cet événement
nous recevons alexandre basse entraîneur
chez les pandas à volants geci
giovanetti entraîneur chez profile 78 la
présidente stéphanie gauthier et les
lèvres rodolphe fano bonsoir alors
pourquoi avoir voulu créer cette
initiative parce que déjà en tant que
ville provient et à ceux des
associations ville proviennent ont été
directement concernés par l'arrivée des
réfugiés tibétains et du fait qu'on a dû
les associations la mairie ils ont mis
en place d'autres structures pour
pouvoir nous accueillir et nous le fait
qu'on pratique des arts martiaux
d'origine chinoise
kung fu notamment et ben connaissant le
sujet on a en a voulu créer une action
pour eux et afin de pouvoir faire un
échange culturel entre les villes
provient et des tibétains donc on a mis
en place ce stage pour pour créer un
lien entre les communautés
stéphanie gauthier finalement ça s'est
fait très rapidement ils sont arrivés la
semaine dernière à villepreux
comment ça s'est passé très vite toute
façon on sait tous concertés très
rapidement tout le monde était vraiment
partant
tout de suite beaucoup de volontaires
donc on a mis tout de suite en place on
voulait vraiment faire quelque chose à
la portée de tous publics
donc notre notre art martial et 1 voilà
il ya des percussions il ya des coups
donc pieds poings projections donc ce
n'était pas à la portée de tout le monde
sans certificat médical donc c'est pour
ça qu'on a demandé à ghislain qui habite
actuellement taïwan qui est un grand
spécialiste du beauf ou traditionnels
pour nous faire un stage ouvert
justement à tout public
donc dès 8 ans voilà alors ça sera un
stage de kung fu traditionnelle de style
hung gar
c'est bien ça qu'est ce que c'est fait
en fait un style traditionnel qu'il ya
plusieurs centaines d'années
en fait qui fait partie du style du sud
de la chine est là notamment en fait
ghislain pratique actuellement à taiwan
depuis nombreuses années par un m ce
style il refait un expert 3e dan ces
experts 3e dan la fédération et donc il
vient là en fait pour les fêtes et en
profite du temps pour le faire un stage
une faire profiter de son savoir faire
et son expérience en nous apprenant en
fait ce style qui est très peu connue en
france pour en faire profiter justement
les villes provient et toute autre
personne
mais comment dire les
les amoureux du kung fu ils vont adorer
ça justement c'est pour qu'ils vous qui
êtes élève est ce que ça vous intéresse
ce que vous allez y être moi je serais
certainement c'est même une certitude
personnellement j'ai pratiqué pas mal de
ouf
dans ma vie donc moi je trouve que c'est
une très très belle action à plusieurs
niveaux que ce soit de partage ou de
communication enfin n'importe quoi c'est
vraiment une bonne chose et et moi j'y
serai certainement et ça sera un grand
plaisir parce que je connais
personnellement
la personne qui va donner le stage donc
j siens et je sais que ce sera un très
bon moment pour tout le monde comment ça
va se dérouler du coup ce sera sur toute
la journée
oui oui alors ça a changé aujourd'hui la
mairie ont eu à voilà il ya eu un petit
oubli de leur part sur le gymnase qu'on
devait occuper précédemment donc là on
est en réorienter sur la salle des fêtes
un peu de villepreux et ça va être le
matin pour tout public donc de 10h à 12h
pour tout le public on fait une petite
pause et l'après midi c'est uniquement
pour les licenciés
d'arts martiaux ou là le ce sera un
petit peu plus poussés par ghislain pour
vraiment faire profiter un grand nombre
de pratiquants c'est pour tous niveaux
c'est bon pour tout niveau effectivement
ça avec le matin ghislain va orienter
son stage pour justement s'adapter à
tous comme il sait le faire donc depuis
le plus jeune âge
huit ans jusqu'à 77 ans 80 ans et a pas
d'âge pour pratiquer et après l'après
midi effectivement plus de stéphanie de
14 heures à 17 heures ce sera peut-être
un petit peu plus poussés par rapport
justement le style qui est pratique et
qui sera enseignée
mais je pense qu'ils ont tout un moment
de partage en qui est fait justement
pour les tibétains ou là en fait la
participation est libre les gens pour
donner ce qu'ils veulent et avoir sa
traversée pour leur cause est ce qu'on
veut en fait c'est par rapport à tous
pratiquants d'arts martiaux ici est ce
qu'on veut c'est un moment de partage 1
1 au monde échanges entre les tibétains
les villes croisiens et ghislain kane
qui a war qui est aussi grand expert et
qui a aussi beaucoup de choses à nous
apporter à travers ce style en fait
d'elle la question vous avez mis sur la
fiche tarif libre c'est à dire est ce
que vous pouvez préciser se dire que je
sens la version se dire que les gens ils
viennent ils apportent ce qu'ils veulent
c'est ici un déjà s'ils veulent
participer c'est très bien après s'ils
veulent donner quelque chose qu'on
une petite pièce à un billet ben nous on
retransmettra ça directement à ses airs
l'association qui s'occupe des réfugiés
tibétains qui pourront acheter peut-être
des micro ondes et les choses qui leur
manque pour améliorer un peu leur
confort de tous les jours merci à tous
les quatre d'être passé sur ce plateau
le stage est programmé ce dimanche 15
descend à partir de 10 heures l'espace
michel petrucciani
c'est déjà la fin de cette émission très
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
il